my guest tonight it's one of the
greatest NBA players of all time he's an
analyst on inside the NBA now you can
see him in the new TNT series Shaq life
please welcome the one the only
Shaquille O'Neal how you doing jack
before we get started I brought you a
gift brother he did yes ever since I've
been on quarantine I'm into carving and
you know clay models and stuff and I
made this for you it's called The Shack
angel oh my God look at that as you can
see their abs are intact as you can see
the wings yes and also May one called
the Shaq warrior this one right here oh
my god these are fantastic I can't wait
to actually have one of those in my
possession you're gonna say yes I will
and I have one more or carving that I
did and once you see it oh yeah okay
this call Shaq loves the kids I did this
one in about 30 minutes as you can see
Shaq with the kids I see there's you
with the kids and into those wings
you always have wings in these yeah yes
because I'm an angel man wait I got one
more carving of Charles Barkley than I
did I see a Charles Barkley carving yeah
yes this is a Charles Barkley baby yeah
I see him I see it you said once that
back when you were playing back in the
day there were certain players that you
would let score on you because you
really respected their game is that true
not respect their game because I liked
their game so for example let's just say
Tracy McGrady is going against Kobe I
say okay Tracy McGrady two or three
plays let me see what you got and then
like you know I said whoa Kobe just you
know I'm saying boo Kobe just quoting
what you gonna do so I would let it go
three at the four position
Allen Iverson was another guy my go
ahead Kobe Gardner or D Fischer gotta
white chocolate Jason Williams was given
for mine he was
because he was very patchy with the ball
only time I did do that was when I was
in playoff mode but other than that yeah
like look even though I'm a player
there's a lot of guys that I really
respect that and I was fans of this game
mostly guards so if I was playing now I
would let Steph Curry score all the time
I love this game he's my favorite player
yeah I remembered we all saw you at
Kobe's memorial and it was amazing
because you were very moving but you
were also very funny at the same time
about Kobe it almost seems like another
lifetime ago since this Cove Eid crisis
but it must still seem unreal to you
that he's not with us this is my
toughest year and I don't complain about
anything but lost my baby sister lost my
good friend we'll ever be together link
and then now people are losing their
lives a lot of people are filing for
unemployment a neighbor who lives next
door been working for Disney for 30
years
got let go the other day so you know I
mean in a conversation it's just it's
just just a tough year but you know I'm
glad there's social media I'm glad
there's DVDs and I'm glad there's
YouTube because when he first passed
away I couldn't believe it I watched
every I watched every playoff game that
we ever played I just sat in my room I
tell people I don't want to talk to
anybody not just I'm like I'm like I'm
just like looking at him like okay it
can't be true because he's right there
on the screen I'm marching but you know
then he got announced you know to the
Hall of Fame
and I probably won't watch that because
it's not gonna be the same without him
all the way I watched it as if his
beautiful wife gives us feature or if
his mother and father gives a speech on
his behalf but no I just you know if I
had to provide two wishes I just wish he
was there and I wish I could take my
sister to the ceremony you know to know
wash and be in duck yeah you know a lot
of us are thinking about our families
right now as we go through this really
difficult time and I know that you have
sons that play and also your daughter
plays and they're very very good and
you've said you think that they will
probably go pro
that is true I try to encourage him but
I already push him I know we always have
family meetings and when they all got of
age I said listen we don't need another
Shack give me a goddamn owns a hedge
fund
give me a pediatrician you me guy that
has his own law firm give me give me a
guy that's you know I was a store
manager it may got at some movie for
just you guys can do anything you want I
don't care if you play basketball or not
but I got three of them ever that really
like to play two of them will be going
to a shoot next year and my youngest who
probably is my best athlete know she can
go anywhere she want but I don't I don't
push him because listen I was good for
us and we don't need basketball one
thing I need you to do is have three
diplomas so when you come into my office
and ask for a loan for your business I
know that you qualify I tell them I you
got to get three degrees to touch any of
Daddy's cheese that's a good bumper
sticker you should you should market
that you know a lot of people are
wondering right now how is the NBA how
are they going to start up again is
there a way some people have proposed
that maybe there could be a bubble city
a place like Vegas where all the players
can get together they can all stay in
the same hotel and play that way I don't
know if that's an insane idea or not and
maybe do it without crowds do you see
anything like that happening in the NBA
soon I don't have an answer I wish I had
an answer for you you know but kudos to
all the league commissioners and guys
that run the league for having the balls
to say you know what I care about the
players and I care about the fans
this thing's gonna spread like this we
don't want to want to you know get out
of control but as a player I don't think
I could could have a great impact
without fans you so the fans are if
you're playing the fans are that crucial
to your experience as a player yes yes
and you know for me is not all about the
fans like I just used to take two or
three people so when it was in LA jack
Adam Sandler Denzel and then
pick a father and a son to just look at
cuz my dad used to always take me to the
game be like you see that guy right
there you see his son he paid all his
damn money make sure you put on the show
so like yes fans very important like if
I go to a game and saw you there
oh I'll be like hey Conan's here he's
not here to see you though many goddamn
ball and watch me go to work that impact
on you you might if you saw me you might
say hey who's that lady hey let's talk
about you popped up you did a cameo in
in Tiger King I know that you visited
him alright yesterday on my day off I
went to the GW Zoo I'll have two eggs
out it Joe I got two more Tigers I
didn't do a cameo the law states that
when you do something to say something
becomes public property so you're right
and correct I
we were we were traveling back and forth
from Dallas OKC so I see a sign that
says we have tigers white tigers I love
white tigers that's my weakness way so I
go and the gentleman is there he's you
know long hair the shirts you know yes I
met that he's there and like you know I
tell people all the time being friendly
to somebody doesn't mean that that we're
friends
I have no have no affiliation with him
or a zoo I like animals yeah every the
country knows my name are made a large
donations too you know for animals to
have food shelter all that good stuff so
I go there listen guy had a nice part he
had like 200 G cats
he let me get some you know little
kitties for us hey I want to buy the
kitties so and that term by means
donation you know I want to buy these
kitties they'll be mine I'm gonna give
you a donation I get to come back to see
him whatever so you know I do that two
years later I come back the other guy
pulls me to the side and said there's
some stuff going on you might not want
to come back here again I never came
back and I think that was 78 years ago
and then finally I'm
shouldn't be DVD because I followed what
was happening and then I never saw one I
see myself when I was like up here we go
in the next area I was going crazy but
America I do not harm animals I love
animals so thank you very much yeah well
what did you think of Joe exotic when
you met him he seems like a to be a
pretty entertaining guy yes she was he
was one you know he was one of those
guys that go to auditions every day and
they want to be a star so bad they'll
just do everything and guess what now is
now he's one of the most famous people
in America but you know who was really
funny the guy with no teeth he was funny
oh yeah he's got teeth now yeah those
yeah I think he got implants a little
money came his way and he got some teeth
okay but that's not his brand no he's
not gonna be for pretty teeth go back to
the no teeth look man well I'll get that
message to him you know I was occurring
to me that one of the things you must
miss his Charles Barkley's face uh I
miss his ass he has a flat ass for black
I always look at him like would make
some booty shots or something like I do
I missed you Chuck is uh my annoying
best friend he's funny he's annoying
he's loud
well yeah I miss him I miss fitting
across from him looking at him I talked
to Sir Charles a little while ago not
too long ago and he started he started
talking some [ __ ] about you he said I
don't believe Shaq uses IcyHot I don't
think he eats at Papa John's I don't
think he's insured by the general how do
you how do you respond to that
okay the general was my first car
insurance when I was at LSU I see how I
do use I see I don't use it now because
I'm not in any aches and pains ok ok I
know I see how it works because one day
I had a PHY bruise and the trainer wrote
it on my thigh and it rolls up to that
area too
to the boys and whoo-wee I was in the
shower with wood milk
I had to pour milk I had to pour milk on
my bullets to get up and I do eat a Papa
John's I'm always in the Papa John's
okay love the story about getting icy
hot on your testicles that was I love
that and milk is the cure if that should
happen yes
all right here's another question I got
to ask you about the advertisements
you've turned down Wheaties you won't do
an ad for Wheaties is a cereal that you
because you don't need them is there are
there cereals that you would do an ad
for if they came to you roasted flakes
is a number one choice and I'll do it
for free
so mr. frost to mr. flakes root loops
I'm damaged and then I was already on
the cover of shorty pebbles I was on the
cover of 39 boxes 40 bubbles and then
the last choice will probably be
probably dig him smack remember dig'em
smacks you what's wrong with that frogs
airplane you know another thing I wanted
to ask you about is when I was talking
to to Berkeley I said to him look
Charles I'm 6 4 I'm pretty quick I'm
good with my hands I think I think I
could have made it in the NBA he told me
no way what do you think you can't you
gotta weigh in on this remember what I
said to you the first time I say I was
like jeez you're tall looking at you on
TV you know look at me you look tall but
what I like talk to you you're like
right there so I don't think you're sick
for I think you're 6 7
well that's the hair oh good point good
point
nice what are you what do you think
would you have feared me if you were
coming down and you saw me covering you
would you be afraid oh oh and love you
know you look like like look like a pale
Brian Scalabrine
I thought you're gonna say I look like
the Wendy's girl hey I'm gonna tell you
one other thing that Charles said about
you he said whenever Shaq and I get into
a basketball argument on the air Shaq
always goes to the same places which is
you don't have any rings is that what
you always say to him
I sure do you don't have one of these
Charles do you could never have you
little baby I'm gonna get [ __ ] from
Charles now and that's all I want to
make sure that I get the word out you
got to tune in and see Shaq life it's
the new TNT series with Shaquille O'Neal
and Shaq you're hilarious thank you very
much you're always great and you know I
can do anything for you okay oh it was
take care Shaq be good